[Musique]
aujourd'hui 27 février à nous de
girardin ministre d outre-mer et dix
églises ministre de l'agriculture ont
remis la médaille d'or ou lauréats dans
l'ensemble des départements d'outre-mer
pour l'excellence de leurs produits dans
le cadre du salon international de
l'agriculture
la réunion a décroché 5 médailles d'or
et deux de bronze au caire mais général
agricole 2020 80 une médaille
aujourd'hui remporté par les territoires
d'outre-mer on a remis les médailles
d'or elles sont nombreuses dans du coup
maintenant on ne remet que les médailles
d'or mais ça montre que l'excellence
dans les territoires d'outre-mer et bien
et bien présentes qu'il faut qu'on
continue à pouvoir effectivement
amélioré l'ensemble de nos produits
je leur dis aussi dans ce salon c'est
une vraie visibilité des territoires
d'outre-mer et de ce que nous nous
produisons dans l'après midi si sur le
stand institutionnel du village réunion
que le département et la chambre
d'agriculture ont accueilli les lauréats
pour la remise des médailles qu'on
fierté pour la collectivité
départementale chef de file de
l'autorité agricole département en tant
que chef de file de la politique
agricole
notre territoire soutient serriculteurs
et au salon international de
l'agriculture ça fait trois ans que le
département a pris l'initiative de
d'installer un village réunionnais de
600 mètres carrés et le département pour
la promotion et l'amélioration de la
qualité de nos produits donc de voir
ainsi de produire et données mises en
valeur c'est une réelle fierté se sont
en effet cinq médailles d'or et deux de
bronze qui ont été décernés dans trois
catégories à nos producteurs avec les
confitures et de la réunion et rome avec
rivière du mât et rome métis et
l'apiculteur bernard savreux primé en
miel clair
donc j'ai reçu la médaille d'or pour le
produit confiture papaye passion ça
représente une reconnaissance de notre
travail parce que ça fait quand même
quinze ans qu'on existe sur l'île de la
réunion et
c'est toujours gratifiant d'avoir un
titre à un moment donné de toute manière
économiquement parlant ça peut apporter
quelque chose parce que les gens ils
sont très sensibles
donc cette reconnaissance est reconnu
par le public
donc les gens sont toujours attirés par
ce titre là alors j'ai eu à une médaille
d'or sur une confiture letchis framboise
une autre médaille d'or sur une
confiture banane citron vert et une
troisième médaille une médaille de
bronze sur une confiture de temps encore
bah ça représente surtout une récompense
pour le travail qui est fait en fait
tout au long de l'année
c'est une grosse récompense pour les
équipes qui travaillent avec moi
toute l'année et c'est un encouragement
à continuer à continuer à mettre en
valeur les productions de la réunion
donc on a reçu la médaille d'argent pour
le punch planteur et la crème de noix de
coco et bassa se rajoute aux 315 autres
médailles qu'on a eue sur les concours
nationaux et internationaux et ça nous
permet de nous faire connaître et et de
confirmer que c'est le meilleur homme de
la réunion et du monde on va dire les 28
exposants du village réunion continue à
représenter notre île à paris jusqu'au
dimanche 1er mars
[Musique]